portland not the only city facing a
crisis chicago under the pathetic
leadership there
of liberal mayor all these cities
liberal
liberal leadership for decades mayor
lightfoot lightweight at this point
violent crime spiraling out of control
this morning three
three chicago police officers shot while
making an arrest coming as the city
is forced to add 200 police to the
downtown tourist district amid another
surge of criminal activity there
carjackings assaults stabbing meanwhile
the office
of city alderman raymond lopez was just
vandalized yet again
this is the third time why he called
chicago lawless
slam lightfoot for failing the people of
chicago joining us
now with more is alderman raymond lopez
along with fox news contributor dan
bongino
uh alderman you're a democrat you know
i what i hear you say is you want we've
been watching the shootings
you know just pick the number what's it
going to be this weekend
60 70 80 people shot how many will die
and how many will be children
you you want your city safe and you're
now
under assault for that yeah for the
third time in
a month my office has been targeted i've
been targeted for standing up to the
gang bangers
who have made it their mission to
terrorize my communities and
you know protecting my residents
defending the safety and security of our
city should not be a partisan issue but
we've seen time and again
my mayor and just across the board
political incompetence for people making
excuses to score political points at the
expense
of our residents our children are
seniors who are all dying and terrified
on the streets of the city you know i
watch this dan bongino i just cannot
believe
that you have it's a myth that this is
happening
obama is saying oh they're going after
peaceful protesters
with tear gas and batons and it's just a
lie and then politicizing it to the
level that he did
which by the way is predictable every
two years every four years
you know sean i agree with you um i
really never thought that they would
come or i would wake up in an america
where in cities that are losing black
men and women
white men and women in droves to
shootings
people being mugged or raped assaulted
on the streets
that the cops would be the enemy the
cops would be the enemy to the point
where you have the speaker of the house
referring to federal agents by the way
sean
the same designation of the federal
agents that protect nancy pelosi
those capitol hill police i don't know
if she told you that as storm troopers
referred to as an occupying force
literally
cops are there for the police folks just
think about this
how does it sound to them the enemy the
worst day of your life
they're the enemy joe biden and john
they're there every single day you're
assaulted who's there first
it's not your mama it ain't daddy it's
the cops
you know you're burglarized your house
who shows up the cops
god forbid your kid is kidnapped they're
missing who shows up
the cops aldermen you're a democrat
let me ask you a question these these
mayors they're they're not doing the
thing to protect people
they're demonizing the police police now
are they
literally disarming them you heard the
seattle police chief this week
you're going to stay a democrat do you
think they're protecting the people in
your city
i believe that there are there's a value
to the democratic party
what are they doing to say they're
they're that's their number one duty
what are they doing to save and protect
lives
i'm not going to argue that the
leadership that we have is failing in
that regard
what they are doing is demonizing law
enforcement that we have worked with for
decades in my communities like in back
of the yards which is one of the most
dangerous communities in the city of
chicago
my local police had working
relationships with the dea
atf and fbi trying to break down the
gang and drug cartels and syndicates in
those neighborhoods
and we have worked well together to do
that what i believe is that we need to
show that as a party
is the party that is aiding and abetting
anarchy is that a true statement
there are some in my party yes but that
does not represent leadership in these
cities
and joe biden are they with their
comments
and obama's comments are they helping
i don't think their comments and more
importantly i don't think their silence
is helping
because every day chicagoans whether
they're democrat or republican
want to feel safe they want their
children to come home and we have to
confront
the enemy within our midst joe and
barack did nothing
to help your city they barely mentioned
it for eight years